despite the president's demand many
state and local officials
won't rule out having fully remote
instruction in the new school year
nearly 600 school districts in new
jersey
have just been given the option to go
completely online this fall it's a
dramatic
shift for the governor he tells meg
oliver why
he changed his mind and the last thing
we want to do
is open a school or a district
irresponsibly after months of insisting
all schools return to some form of
in-person learning
new jersey governor phil murphy is now
changing course
looking ahead to the fall what is your
main goal
our main goal is to get to in-person
instruction but to do it safely
we're now saying to school districts
that don't feel that they can get there
on day one
safely with all the health protocols
we're going to work with them to get
them there
and yet he's not ruling out ordering a
statewide all remote learning mandate
even at the 11th hour i think
superintendents are extremely concerned
they're wasting their time
developing these hybrid models no
they're not wasting their time
even if at the last minute you have to
say hey we have to go all remote
you just can't take off the table that
this thing is going to
rear its head and we have to be prepared
for that english teacher tom
keita says he's frustrated about the
lack of direction but knows there's no
simple solution
it seems like our leadership doesn't
have a clear
view on what it is that they want to do
for all people
and for all students and i i understand
that
across the country schools are facing
the same difficult reality
in one suburban county near atlanta more
than 1200 students and staff were forced
to quarantine
after dozens tested positive for
coronavirus
but others like these parents in
pennsylvania are pushing for their
districts to reopen
and even advocating for substitutes to
come in if teachers are concerned about
returning
no teacher is saying we don't want to
work we're ready to go back to the
classroom absolutely
when it's safe
[Music]
about four communities here in new
jersey are already making plans to begin
the school year remotely
the state's largest teachers union say
leaving the decision to reopen schools
up to districts can lead to chaos
in a statement they said the stakes are
too high and the consequences of making
a wrong decision
are too grave vlad
it's all about doing it safely as the
governor told you meg thank you very
much